and of course valentine's day on the
horizon once again it is time for the
roaster it's time for the rose test all
right okay if you've missed it five
bouquets as you can see five different
flower shops and we're trying to figure
out which one's going to last the
longest
on saturday two of them are from online
two are from local florist and one of
them is from a store in town so we're
trying to see which ones last the
longest and again we've been going so
what do you say on your side well so
we're kind of taking a close up and and
these two on this end i think are doing
pretty well all right and if i had to
guess i'd say they were the more
expensive ones and we should point out
we don't know which is which we
genuinely don't know here the the place
where we bought them from uh the again
the two stores the online outlet and
then the uh the store is trader joe's we
just don't know which one is which we
will reveal it
on friday and tomorrow we'll tell you
the prices now the the flowers on my end
of the table here
it's not looking great i'll be perfectly
honest with you that we freshened up the
water gave them a little tlc but the
flowers they're they're kind of you
can't do anything about that when it
goes
like no yeah so we'll keep an eye on
these all throughout the rest of the
week and let you know which ones come
out on top so that when you go to buy
flowers for valentine's day maybe some
roses you know what might be the best
option for you you've got to make the
right choice those look beautiful these
are her
oh i want this one i'll take this one
home when it's all done okay we're going
to keep checking throughout the week fun
stuff every morning right here on eight
news now let's talk about the weather
right now